TUCKER.
>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER,
THANKS FOR THAT.
THE PIPE BOMBS OF COURSE ARE ONE
OF MANY EXAMPLES OF ATTEMPTED
AND ACTUAL POLITICAL VIOLENCE
WE'D SEEN.
ONE OF THE MOST NOTABLE WAS A
ATTEMPTED MASSACRE IN THE SUMMER
OF 2017, SO CONGRESSMAN STEVE
SCALISE WAS GRAZED THOUGH MY
GRAVELY WOUNDED.
IN RESPONSE TO THE PIPE BY
MAILING HE TWEETED "THESE
ATTEMPTED ATTACKS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE OR BEYOND CRIMINAL, THEY
ARE ACTS OF TERROR.
IT VIOLENCE AND TERROR HAVE NO
PLACE IN OUR POLITICS OR
ANYWHERE ELSE IN OUR SOCIETY.
THE CONGRESSMAN JOINS US
TONIGHT.
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR COMING ON.
WHAT WAS YOUR FIRST REACTION
WHEN YOU SAW THIS NEWS TODAY?
>> ITS ANGER.
THIS ISN'T THE WAY THAT WE
SHOULD EXPECT AMERICA TO BE
TURNING.
YOU ARE SEEING MORE AND MORE OF
THIS AND CLEARLY YOU ARE SEEING
IT ON BOTH SIDES.
WE ALL NEED TO BE CALLING IT
OUT.
OBVIOUSLY WE NEED TO FIND OUT
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE FBI IS IN
THE PROCESS OF DOING IT.
I FEEL VERY CONFIDENT THAT OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS ARE
ULTIMATELY GOING TO FIND OUT WHO
DID THIS AND IF IT'S ONE OR
MULTIPLE PEOPLE, TO BRING THEM
TO JUSTICE AND DO IT AS SWIFTLY
AS POSSIBLE.
>> Tucker: 'S OF THE CONDEMNED
THESE ACTS AND WAS IMMEDIATELY
REBUKED BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
FORWARD CONDEMNING THE ACTS NOT
QUITE ENOUGH, WHAT YOU MAKE OF
THAT?
>> I THOUGHT THAT WAS A MISTAKE
ON THEIR PART TO CRITICIZE THE
PRESIDENT.
I THINK IT WAS IMPORTANT TO THE
PRESIDENT DID COME OUT WITH A
STATEMENT THE WAY HE DID,
STRONGLY.
I HEARD SILENCE A LOT OF TIMES
WHEN REPUBLICANS WERE UNDER
ATTACK FROM DEMOCRAT LEADERS.
WE ALL SHOULD BE CALLING THIS
OUT.
WHEN A REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT IS
UNDER ATTACK -- FIRST OF ALL, WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO DID IT.
WE SHOULD BE TRYING TO FIND OUT
WHO DID IT BUT WE SHOULD BE
CRITICIZING THE ACT WHETHER IT'S
A REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT.
SOME PEOPLE ONLY CRITICIZE WHEN
IT'S A DEMOCRAT UNDER ATTACK.
AND THE MEDIA, BY THE WAY, WAS
UNDER ATTACK AND THERE'S NO
PLACE FOR THAT EITHER.
>> Tucker: HOW DO WE
DE-ESCALATE THIS?
THINGS SEEM TO BE MOVING IN A
DIRECTION THAT'S OMINOUS AND SO
WHAT OUR LEADERS NEED TO DO TO
PULL US BACK TO >> I THINK THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING IS TO GET
BACK TO WHAT MADE THIS COUNTRY
GREAT.
OUR FOUNDERS DIDN'T SET UP SOME
KIND OF SYSTEM WHERE EVERYBODY
HAD TO THINK THE SAME WAY.
IN FACT, THEY CHALLENGED THEIR
GOVERNMENT AND THEY WANTED A
SYSTEM WHERE INDIVIDUAL PEOPLE
CAN SPEAK THEIR VIEWS AND EVEN
SPEAK OUT AGAINST THEIR
GOVERNMENT AND THEY PUT THE
FIRST AMENDMENT ULTIMATELY IN
THE CONSTITUTION TO ENSURE THAT
RIGHT BUT THE DIFFERENCE IS WE
ALL HAVE OUR DISAGREEMENTS.
YOU SHOULD NEVER MAKE THOSE
PERSONAL AND YOU SHOULD NEVER
THINK THAT VIOLENCE IS A WAY TO
SETTLE OUR POLITICAL DIFFERENCE
DIFFERENCES.
WE SETTLE THEM AT THE BALLOT
BOX.
WE HAVE AN ELECTION IN 13 DAYS,
THAT'S WHERE WE SETTLE OUR
DIFFERENCES.
VIOLENCE IS NEVER AN ANSWER TO
SOMEBODY'S POLITICAL
DISAGREEMENT WITH SOMEBODY ELSE.
>> Tucker: IT'S A WISE AND
INTERESTING POINT YOU MAKE.
YOU ARE SANE PEOPLE FEEL LESS
FREE TO EXPRESS THEIR OPINIONS
NOW THAN THEY HAVE IN PREVIOUS
GENERATIONS AND THAT PART OF THE
REASON THINGS ARE SO VOLATILE?
>> WHEN SOMEBODY TRIES TO USE
THREATS OR INTIMIDATION IF LIKE
THE SCHOOLYARD BULLY.
IF THEY DON'T WANT TO CONFRONT
THEIR OWN DEMONS THEY TRY TO
THREATEN YOU AND SCARE YOU AWAY
FROM JUST LIVING YOUR EVERYDAY
LIFE AND THAT'S NOT WHO WE ARE
AS AMERICANS.
YOU SAW AFTER SEPTEMBER 11TH
WHEN OUR VERY WAY OF LIFE WAS
UNDER ATTACK BY PEOPLE WHO HAD A
TOTALLY DIFFERENT VIEWPOINT OF
AMERICA AND WHAT IT STANDS FOR
AND WE CAME TOGETHER AS A
COUNTRY AND WE SAID WE ARE NOT
GOING TO BACK DOWN, WE ARE NOT
GOING TO CHANGE WHO WE ARE AND
WE SHOULDN'T DO IT HERE EITHER
BUT WE SHOULD BE EQUALLY
VIGILANT.
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRAT, NO
MATTER WHO WAS UNDER ATTACK,
THAT IT'S WRONG FOR WHOEVER DID
THE ATTACK.
IT LETS FIND OUT THE DETAILS,
DON'T TRY TO DEFLECT BLAME TRY
TO BLAME SOMEBODY ELSE WHO HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
LET'S ACTUALLY GO AFTER THE
PEOPLE WHO DID.
THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD DO AND
COMING TOGETHER AS AMERICANS AND
AGAIN, IT'S NOT ABOUT
PHILOSOPHY.
I'M A CONSERVATIVE, I HAVE
LIBERAL FRIENDS.
I DISAGREEMENTS WITH THEM BUT I
DON'T MAKE IT PERSONAL AND NONE
OF US SHOULD MAKE IT PERSONAL.
WE SHOULD WANT TO FIND OUT WHO
DID IT.
GET THE FACTS.
DON'T GO TRYING TO BRING PEOPLE
THAT HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
THIS.
LET'S ALL BE FOCUSED ON COMING
TOGETHER IN FINDING OUT WHO DID
IT AND BRINGING THEM TO JUSTICE.